[Musique]
il fallait casser le holland machine et
le président a fait sacrifice de sa
candidature pour casser la machine
je pense que c'est un acte assez
courageux c'est satan montrait qu'un
politique et pas forcément un crochet au
pouvoir et qui peu de temps en temps par
les oreilles ouvertes
objectivement il a été poussé vers la
sortie faut quand même pas rêver et pas
franchement le fait que je crois qu'il
repart comme il est arrivé c'est à dire
par dépit et peut-être même par hasard
finir il a été expulsé de l'élection
présidentielle il l'a été par ses
propres amis qui ont tout fait pour
l'empêcher d'être candidat c'est parce
que vous visez quelqu'un en particulier
c'est manuel vals j'imagine mais moi je
ne vise personne pour que vous annoncer
que je ne sais pas si on ne sait pas qui
de françois hollande manuel valls et la
lame ou le manche du couteau qui a
déchiré la gauche manuel valls a
théorisé les gauches irréconciliables
pour ma part je veux les gauches
réconcilier lance un appel à emmanuel
macron à jean luc mélenchon
rejoignez la primaire de la gauche fait
en sorte que l'unité serait allé
le vainqueur de cette primaire de gauche
ne sera pas soutenue par ses concurrents
malheureux cette primaire c'est ok
corral la conclut-il on ne peut pas être
président sans avoir de débat sans avoir
de combat il faut s'affronter un petit
peu on n'est pas dans l'univers ouaté
des hauts fonctionnaires désignés par
les politiques
grâce à fidel castro les cubains ont
récupéré leur territoire leur vie leur
destin sur son analyse du castrisme je
ne me retrouve pas et pour moi fidel
castro est loin d'être un parangon de
vertus démocratiques
certains ne vont pas se rhabiller à bon
compte au nom des droits de l'homme
alors qu'on sait que ici quand on
demande et liste des prisonniers
politiques on en a pas fournissez - les
listes de prisonniers politiques à ce
moment là on pourra faire quelque chose
il n'y a pas de limite aux bêtises que
les responsables politiques peuvent dire
plus jamais de leçons de la gauche sur
les droits de l'homme après l'éloge de
castro par un ministre socialiste ryle
fillonniste thierry mariani ça me
rappelle une autre déclaration que
ségolène royal avait fait autrefois pour
présenter la justice chinoise en exemple
pour la justice française par combien de
havanes at-elle fumée se moque le député
socialiste guy delcourt
seul jean luc mélenchon salue la sortie
de la ministre par alexandre jardin
lorsqu'à à l'élection présidentielle oui
le mouvement les citoyens va présenter
un candidat ce sera moi oui je suis
candidat à la présidence de la
république à lui aujourd'hui de trouver
les mots les comportements les attitudes
pour réunir pour fédérer pour pour
rassembler sinon je suis pas fâché du
tout je les pense aux pas coupé mais il
appelle par son porte parole pour
annoncer sa candidature à la
présidentielle c'est au delà des mots
c'est une conviction totale
je veux tout donner tout donner pour la
france qui m'a tant donné
le président de la république française
sortant qui devait être candidat à sa
propre succession se retrouvent dans
l'incapacité de se présenter parce que
et macron evans ont tout organisé pour
le faire renoncer
et lorsqu'on pense que c'est françois
hollande qui a fait leur carrière
et bien voilà c'est le combat des
traîtres à gauche aujourd'hui pour les
raisons que je vous ai dit je prendrait
du temps
et je ferai mon choix avec le recul
nécessaire à françois hollande je veux
dire mon émotion mon affection
sa décision est celle d'un homme d'état
qui place l'intérêt général au-dessus de
tout le problème n'est pas d'être le
candidat de la gauche ou même de gagner
une primaire
le problème est de savoir comment on est
unis non pas autour d'un homme
providentiel d'une femme providentiel
mais autour de nos valeurs
on sent qu'il a du mal à garder ses
nerfs et on le voit souvent très énervé
très agressif
ce qui n'est pas rassurant pour
quelqu'un qui veut maîtriser le bouton
nucléaire où l'ensemble des
responsabilités qui incombent un chef de
l'état part j'ai pu avoir des mots durs
susciter des débats des incompréhensions
c'est ça la gauche c'est le débat c'est
la controverse mais j'ai toujours assumé
les décisions collectives parce que
c'est ça aussi l'esprit de la gauche
pourrait vous connaissez un meilleur
candidat
j'en connaissais et je serai présente
pour soutenir un candidat qui représente
le coeur des valeurs du parti socialiste
évident on va voir c'est lui qui avait
voulu je crois des pâtes débaptiser le
parti socialiste fait là il a un certain
nombre d'éléments à son actif
biographique qui montre qu' il n'était
pas toujours finalement dans la
tradition politique que georges blanc
mais après tout je ne donne aucune leçon
à personne ce que doit être la cause
quant à emmanuel macron en voyage à new
york il n'a pas souhaité commenter cette
candidature concurrente depuis
l'étranger sans surprise c'est bernard
cazeneuve qui remplace manuel valls 22e
premier ministre de la vème république
et celui qui restera le moins longtemps
à l'hôtel matignon est un ami d'être un
frère
c'est rare en politique de pouvoir
compter et pouvoir s'appuyer sur des
hommes de qualité comme vous ce choix
arrive un peu tard moi j'aurais préféré
que il soit premier ministre avant mais
il a montré en pratique qu'il était
quelque part le contraire de ce qu'a été
manuel valls ces derniers mois je veux
vous dire mon indéfectible amitié mon
profond respect et ma très grande
reconnaissance pour la manière dont nous
avons travaillé ensemble au cours des
derniers mois et cela porte un nom dans
la vie politique et croyez-moi ça existe
l'amitié par protéger c'est la mission
que j'ai confié aussi à bernard
cazeneuve comme premier ministre mais
protégé ne suffit pas il faut préparer
l'avenir
je le connais bernard cazeneuve une de
ses phrases un jour profondément là il
m'a dit notre problème en politique
c'est qu'à gauche à droite ya des fous
et qu'à gauche il ya des cons c'est un
autre fidèle du président qui prend sa
place à l'intérieur c'est une grande
responsabilité dans la période d'être le
ministre de l'intérieur et d'avoir
assuré avec le président de la
république avec le premier ministre la
protection totale des français c'est un
gouvernement sans ambition sans projet
sans programme donc ça sera le
liquidateur du passif du bilan de ce
gouvernement sortant part il y a eu bien
sûr des erreurs des échecs ne vont pas
atteint tous les objectifs mais nous
avons contribué je crois encore une fois
à redresser le pays sur l'économie sur
l'industrie c'est un adversaire cabossée
ils sont carbonisés ils sont cramés sont
ils sortent de laruns et j'invite les
hommes de les femmes de gauche de
progrès les républicains ceux qui ne
veulent pas d'ailleurs ni l'extrême
droite ni du programme très dur de
françois fillon je les invite évidemment
à venir dans cette primaire
j'invite plutôt les progressistes de
gauche comme ceux du centre de la droite
à me rejoindre pour faire en sorte qu'
il n'y ait pas au second tour une à st
le choix entre le front national et une
droite conservatrice je dis à mes
compatriotes
n'ayez pas peur et je dis aux candidats
qui se reconnaissent dans cette gauche
qui assume les responsabilités
n'ayez pas peur c'est pourquoi vous êtes
invités non parce que marion maréchal-le
pen a refusé mon invitation elle était
invitée vendredi la survie du
remplacement dans une interview accordée
au quotidien catholique d'extrême droite
présents marion maréchal-le pen revient
sur le remboursement de l'avortement
il faudra revenir sur le remboursement
intégral est illimité de l'avortement
car les femmes sont des êtres
responsables qui doivent être traités
comme tels par cas et pourquoi ne vient
pas non pour ne pas parler de
l'avortement et les divergences qui
laquelle son émission a avorté
je ne remettrait pas en cause l'accès
ali vg de quelque manière que ce soit
donc j'espère que les choses ont été
entendus français sauf que vous ne ferez
rien ou presque dans les quelques
semaines qui nous séparent de l'élection
présidentielle ils savent bien c'est que
le dernier gouvernement de françois
hollande ne fera pas en quatre mois ce
qu'il a été incapable de faire en quatre
ans
je voudrais tout d'abord vous remercier
pour la manière très bienveillante
absolument aimable avec laquelle vous
avez eu la gentillesse de me souhaiter
la bienvenue près ministres ont
néanmoins le droit de soutenir tel ou
tel ben j'imagine que ça va quand même
je sens du message du ministre de
l'intérieur
d'accord l'intérieur de l'intérieur je
voyais j'ai du premier ministre moi je
me permettais vous êtes 3 je suis seul
laissez moi une carence car calcat
pardon puisque madame oui pourquoi
seriez vous seriez vous d'ailleurs
excepté mais pourquoi pas du tout perdre
j'espère qu'il va se faire engueuler on
peut pas se présenter comme ça du jour
au lendemain à la présidence de la
république donc à chaque chose en son
temps on n'avait jamais eu l'ambition
non pas pour pas pour cette fois en tout
cas je sais pas après on peut jamais
dire jamais un de plus à son tour
vincent peillon ancien ministre de
l'éducation devrait annoncer sa
candidature à la primaire de la gauche
sur l'opération vincent peillon pour qui
j'ai du respect est une opération
pathétique
parce que il s'agit uniquement de
dézinguer un autre candidat recalé
beaucoup de candidats
ça change pas grand chose non je pense
que ça
ça a pas de répercussions importantes en
visite cet après midi dans le doubs
l'intéressé réagi mais à l'écart des
caméras on ne peut pas être candidat
pour affaiblir
c'est ma conception on ne peut pas être
candidat contre moi vous ne souhaitez
pas vous présenter aux primaires de vous
jeter par la fenêtre et je m'en charger
personnellement de nouvelles
candidatures à l'élection présidentielle
celle de michèle alliot marie qui a
refusé de participer à la primaire à
droite
ce matin on va venir voir le valls on va
voir ce qu'il a envie de nous dire y
avait même une dame qui disait il faut
qu'il sourie
je souris longue avec vous tous je
m'occupe de mon projet pour le pays du
projet qu'on veut porter pour le pays
au delà des clivages qui pour partie
sont artificiels ou le tai chi callas
deux clans qui ne m'intéresse pas
j'aimerai toujours évidemment les
réformes que nous avons engagées mais
aujourd'hui je ne suis plus premier
ministre
je suis candidat à la présidence de la
république
je suis libre j'ai pas parlé de votre
bilan
parce que ça me déprimerait trop 1 n'est
pas fait que des sottises a été attaqué
vous allez l'assumé totalement ce bilan
nous adorent fait une seule primaire
avec c'est à vous de les convaincre
arrêter de suite comme des gamins dans
une cour de récré pourquoi le changement
n'est pas venu parce que l'état a été
trop faible avec les forts et trop dur
avec les faibles
j'écrirai à jean luc mélenchon et
emmanuel macron faut leur proposer de
rejoindre la primaire les mêmes qui
aujourd'hui me demande d'aller à cette
primaire monsieur cambadélis par exemple
vous êtes là peureux dit il mais il a
raison si j'étais un peureux j'aurais
pas quitter le gouvernement
j'aurais pas décidé à l'époque on me
disait que j'étais fou je ne désespère
pas de le convaincre prix maintenant
qu'en effet ce rassemblement de
progressis que nous avons construit
commencent à leur faire peur il faudrait
qu'on aille se perd dans les chicaillas
de la primaire du parti socialiste
quand on dit que vous êtes derrière la
candidature de vincent peillon film et
c'est ce qui se dit vous savez je juste
puisque je suis chez vous je veux
démentir ce retrait dépôt parce que les
prochaines heures
absolument il abaisse la politique car
la décision vient de tomber
pour jérôme cahuzac cinq ans
d'inéligibilité
mais surtout trois ans de prison ferme
sinon pas de commentaires à faire c'est
une décision de justice marque jérôme
cahuzac en mentant devant le parlement
sur le fait qu'il avait un compte en
suisse a commis une faute qui justifiait
aux yeux de la justice une peine lourde
mais qui s'est passé
[Musique]